hey there and welcome to the course I'm
Jess :
and I'm Cameron Pittman we're going to
be your instructors for this course
now you're probably wondering why this
course is called not your typical intro
to HTML and CSS that's because we're not
going to show you how to make a webpage
with a title and some body to start
instead we're going to show you a
methodical way of breaking down a
current web page and recreating it for
your own purposes HTML and CSS develop
and change over time but the underlying
principles will always remain the same
once you get a hang of those learning
the specific techniques is going to
become a lot easier in the first lesson
you'll learn how to look at a basic
design mock-up and translate it to HTML
and CSS to create a basic web page and
in the second lesson you'll develop a
CSS framework which will help you make
websites much faster and easier along
the way you'll learn about responsive
design which is a principle that will
help you reach people on any device that
they're using to see your website in the
last lesson you'll be taking on a
professional framework you'll be
building a static website using
Twitter's bootstrap framework which is
what professionals use in the field
every day now this course is just the
beginning of your journey to become a
front-end web developer here you'll
build the foundations of your own online
portfolio we are really excited to have
you so welcome to class and let's get
started